hey there reject nation
Greg Alba here and I'm breaking the
fourth wall yes we are by talking to you
guys today cuz we watch Deadpool to last
night really late night showing this is
gonna be a non-spoiler review that was
really surprised by how much you could
actually spoil with this movies so we
are gonna be doing a spoiler review cuz
there's a plenty of fun great things to
talk about non spoiler going into that
so quickly before hopping into this I
want to give a page from the day shout
out to Kent McKnight Kent McKnight
without revealing anything too personal
this guy had surgery recently and it was
really serious thing Kent I am so happy
that your surgery went well last time we
talked in messages you are really hopped
up on a lot of prescriptions same
prescriptions when releases drugs this
guy just there's a lot of drugs yeah it
was just like I had surgery gotta up
that cocaine intake he's really just
heavily intoxicated post-surgery you
know what you had a tough time you have
to go through the surgery I say you go
ahead and do as many drugs as you want
and go back to hiding on the last Jedi
cuz I know it's what brings you joy in
life but can't we love you buddy
glad to hear you're doing better my
friend alright so the plot of this movie
I'm only gonna go off of what the
trailers reveal to you about the plot
because there's very specific things
about the set up that would be too
spoiler happy to reveal here the plot
that they'll at least give away in the
trailer cable comes from the future and
he's going after this kid named Russell
aka a mutant with you know like a pyro
kind of power except they all come from
his hands yeah lets out fire there's a
very specific reason why Deadpool wants
to protect him that's how the adventure
begins
I just want to tell you guys this film
just made me really happy it did from
beginning to end I was just a very happy
camper I was surprised by how much Glee
I was feeling because this film it's a
sequel that is darker yet in my opinion
funnier
it's exactly what Judd Apatow wanted to
do with funny P if you look at Deadpool
won the first half of Deadpool won they
come back and forth between Deadpool's
journey where he's Deadpool in the
costume and
wait Wilson what Louis leading up to
becoming separate and the way Wilson's
section has its humorous parts of him in
Vanessa but it gets pretty serious and
dark for a lot of that'll the cancer
stuff and the transformation stuff is
pretty heavy and then here it's kind of
spread out it goes in between dark
emotional stuff and then really funny
stuff dark emotional and really funny
stuff it was pretty surprising by how
great of a tone
David leach was able to find with this
film because it centers around Wade as a
character like the rules all apply
through Wade's so when the heavier stuff
happens to him the movie will shift into
that tone and it works surprisingly well
like the drama and the comedy never feel
like they're encroaching it doesn't ever
feel totally imbalanced because there
are times where you're like are we
getting too dark and then something
hilarious will just happen I don't think
I've seen a movie that can master that
level because you get even more meta
humor you get even way more fourth-wall
breaking it's like it takes itself so
unserious Lee as a movie but it takes
its characters seriously yeah cuz the
jokes are still coming from within the
characters so the film is just really
fun even though it's darker hair a lot
about everybody everything that's going
on I think in this one a big difference
that I noticed is in deadpool 1 Wade
Wilson is as a human being as a
three-dimensional character but when
he's like Deadpool he's more of just a
cartoon character because of specific
plot points that occur in this movie and
the journey that he's going on
he's just Deadpool the whole movie even
when he has the costume on even with all
the fourth wall breaking all the meta
humor all the cartoon enos of him he
feels like a three-dimensional character
even in the costume you could actual
care he could feel the emotions and he
has an art in everything I thought it
was well justified of how they're
turning him into more of a superhero
because they still do it in good
Deadpool fashion is so gradual to I was
worried that like are you gonna like
ruin the antihero qualities of this guy
I could - awe some cliffs I was kind of
concerned about that but I thought they
found a great blend out of how to turn
him into a hero and with a great
emotional journey for Deadpool
piggybacking really nicely off the first
film and one of the things I have to
appreciate most about both of these
together is mazes is just the fact that
they bother to make way to character the
grows and develops yeah there's like a
lot of with them don't get to without
sacrificing the style of a Deadpool
movie I feel like that's the the the
happy byproduct of what anarchie the
tone gets to be is that you can just be
serious and it also works yeah there's
so many flavors to choose from and the
movie is bigger it's crazier way more
nutty the plot is is a much bigger
mission than the first one the first one
is pretty simple this one's much bigger
yet it's still personal I love that they
managed to capture that because you can
watch the trailer it's like is I gonna
get too big in this one but it doesn't
get like MCU Kay yeah it's weirdly
grounded still well yeah the caliber and
the scale of the action the first one is
definitely built upon in this one but it
doesn't feel like there are just no
physics anymore or anything like that
speaking of action the action scenes in
this movie hope they topped the first
one by afar it's like that was the one
thing I was certain that this movie
would do because you get the guy behind
John wick yeah to do the action scenes
in it you're like you're probably gonna
get better action and you certainly do
and a bigger budget does help the action
sequences here are awesome and
choreography choreographies more on that
yeah there's some great gum plan here
some great hand-to-hand combat here or
some movies much more gory than the last
one whoa gory and they full advantage of
Deadpool with the gory yeah I don't like
him so because there's some weird things
on screen I would say that cable
probably has the best action sequences
especially cables first actual action
scene this is so cool it's so cool and
it's the one fight where you're like the
guy who did they all make a fight scene
where you see that really that's
definitely the job with director that's
like super smooth just like aurilla yeah
fish it hard-hitting yeah impact bone
crunch at ass and Josh Brolin in this
film is great I thought he was a good
counterpart for for Deadpool I mean it
goes along in line for the cadet bull
and cable had their own comic book
series here he is set up as the
antagonist of the film Josh Brolin has
less lines in here than he does his dad
house that works for the character yeah
when they built the character up really
well too because there's been such a
to-do about finally see on cable and the
way the movie grad
and introduces him as perfect i watch
interviews would like josh brolin and
ryan reynolds and they have such great
chemistry in just those interviews in
this film their chemistry is great he's
the perfect foil for Deadpool because
that pool is varied you know all nice
guys so non serious but this humor that
definitely comes from that domino yeah
jay-z beats with Atlanta's was a
definite highlight when I saw the
trailers I was like I bet she's gonna be
a highlight and then sure enough she is
she's that character they talk about the
treasures power is luck and they don't
really show you how those powers work in
the trailer it's really cool
what's a Z beats reaction to so many
things brilliant she's she's great in
the movie yeah her characterization is
so strangely magical and there's
something about the power of luck for
her that is oddly unique in a superhero
setting too I mean there's a character
in the flash show that has that power
but it's done way better here the kid
who plays Russell this dude from New
Zealand that was an interesting touch to
have like the child mutant character
there's a very specific line that I
don't want to give away that has a good
touch on who this character is and I
like that a lot of the themes of this
movie rested on this characters journey
yeah like he doesn't take out majority
of the screen time but he's such an
important character in the film and to
Deadpool and I thought the kid did a
great job like he does a great job yeah
very funny and he's like kind of
menacing it don't want to touch on the
x-force characters because they don't
really show them in the trailers Peter
Peter Peter has wrongfully I wasn't
really distracted by a TJ Miller's
presence in here he has some funny
moments too yeah one he actually kind of
plays a character as weasel that's not
thousand percent TJ Miller he's got a
little bit more rafts and even with him
I like they got kind of meta and like
acknowledge the fact that he's always
describing things in really eccentric
yeah yeah but at the end of the day this
still was Deadpool's movie a lot of
characters in this movie shine but but
the true star of this movie is
definitely Ryan Reynolds everyone's
reacting to Deadpool no matter who the
characters are everybody is forced to
react to and reckon with Deadpool and
another thing that I love that they did
this film did really
was there are some jokes in here that
are that are callbacks like reminiscent
of jokes that were made in the first one
and I don't want to give any of those
away but what I thought was smart about
it is they don't feel like rehash you
know like there's some comedy sequels
like hangover 2 or even Austin Powers 2
you're like you're just doing the same
jokes yeah I remember that yeah they're
just like remember how funny wasn't the
first one when we said it like airplane
to this movie doesn't do that they have
jokes that are built upon jokes from the
first one bits from the first one but
they make them better and bigger like
their jokes they build upon that I
thought worked even better this time
around it was a funnier more memorable I
don't remember very many cheap or wasted
call but no definitely not I wanted to
wait because sometimes we shoot these
reviews like immediately after I felt
like I loved this movie more than the
last one I just felt that it's just
impressive in a different way to me yeah
they're different films I prefer this
one I do I love this one I just love
this from this movie there were times
where it's occurred on screen where I
was like that's brilliant
yeah yeah that's brilliant I think both
the Deadpool movies are very special in
terms of modern blockbusters in terms of
modern superhero stuff but yes at least
right now thank you back I just have
such a sense of Glee that rises from it
and when I think about Deadpool 2 right
now and especially coming off the heels
of infinity war it's nice because it
really is I highly recommend you go
check this out I don't know if you'll
prefer it over the first one either way
if you don't prefer I'm sure you'll
still enjoy I got yeah you gotta at
least have fun alright guys well thanks
for watching keep a look out for our
spoiler review we'll be uploading it
very very soon actually there's plenty
to talk about there and won't be like a
full analysis full breakdown we're just
gonna cut go over some of our favorite
moments in it you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron eject today speaking of patron
eject David Gandy thanks for this
Deadpool polo